So with this film I feel like fashion
plays a big role in kind of how your
character goes on a journey like she
goes from fitted suits to kind of loose
trousers yes was that really important when
you were getting into the character yeah
the track the trousers that Juliet wears
when she gets to the island were very
important to me I was like I tried them
on I was like this has to happen.
I hadn't, having done a couple of period
films, hadn't ever had the opportunity to
wear trousers so it felt really
important to me and they were also
trousers that Cate Blanchett once wore in
an old film because they're angels where
you go to try and all these costumes so
that was like this is like a good luck
omen but yeah you sort of feel that in
London she's she's sort of oppressed by
the war and her kind of sense of unease
and feeling very stuck and I
think when she gets the island she
really learns how to sort of release and
breathe and and trust in her own sort of
instincts really and I think that is
reflected by the what she was given that
it's island life and it's sunny and she
goes into these sort of more floaty
dresses and and into these trousers and
these jeans and it's great. It feels, as
romantic comedies go, it's actually quite
feminist and it's quite nice is this is
it quite, when you look back at kind of
the old kind of rom-coms or kind of
period dramas, is it quite refreshing to
play a role I mean you did Price and
Prejudice and Zombies which is ultimate feminist
but was it quite enjoyable to kind of have a
feminist rom-com? Yeah I mean I love
that that whilst this is a story that
and is ultimately she does fall in love
and it is about that and as well as but
it's also about this sort of finding a
family and friendship but alongside that
it's a woman that you know is she's
she's following her own path she's a
writer and and and and just as much as
sort of the fact that she does fall in
love there's this thing of like finding
her own voice and and and getting her
book out, finding her story and and
fulfilling that as a sort of as a
creative person so and she makes all the
big choices you know she's the one that
asked him to marry her she sort of she
takes charge of her life in a way she
learns to do that and is rewarded for
that
which is important and it's told from
her perspective you know it's her story. And obviously when you're
used to film sets so there's lots of
makeup and you know at the end of the
day what's kind of your thing that you do
the minute you're kind of off set and
you're like I want to just go back to
being Lily? What do I do when I finish? I
don't you know I, when your location is
really nice because you end up just
usually just having like going to the
pub and having one like a little drink
just to calm down at the end of it day
and and actually here in corn - when we
filmed in Cornwall, Glen and I who
plays Mark we'd go on like quite big
long walks and and Jess and I did as
well walks along the seafront and that's
a really nice thing to do when you're
somewhere is to sort of really take in
where you are. I find by being by the sea
really calms me yeah. I think in this
movie like Dawsey he's an ally and
we're talking about allies these days
and how men can do that. What do you
think, what would be your advice to the
kind of men who want to be allies to
women, not just in Hollywood but like in
general? How can we be better? Dorsey he takes his time, he listens, he
doesn't invade in her space or try to
sort of control the situation he lets he
lets her be he lets they let themselves
it's like a conversation they find each
other they suss each other out there's
a lot of space and generosity it's
whereas with Mark as sort of he does
have his great qualities but it's
all sort of it's quite sort of invasive
and and and there's not much space for
her to sort of make her own choices
within the relationship and so she ends
up just sort of going along with it
because in some respects what he offers
is a sort of a viable choice but with
Dorsey he's got kind eyes and he listens.
I think yeah I'd say that. So listen? Yeah, listen. Thank you so much.